okay so uh
now i have the last stop of the session
before the breaking session right here
we'll talk about the miracle or
precision
thank you
all right thanks to the organizers um
great to meet everyone um yes i'm james
i'm a faculty at stanford so excited to
share with you some of the recent work
we've been doing in thinking about how
to use at least very large scale
real-world clinical genomics data
both to design like you know in silicon
clinical trials and also to advance
precision oncology
um
maybe if i show the next slide just a
quick question so
how
old do you think it's the
very first clinical trial
anybody want to get make a guess you
know 100 years old 500
yeah how how far back do you think
clinical trial goes
the bible in book of daniel
okay yeah
okay so maybe you have seen this
my
uh this before yeah so actually the
one of the first clinical trial right
that i could find in records actually
goes back to about 2600 years ago
right
yeah
i've also given this talks before
so
so the idea here is actually very
interesting story
right so the king of babylon the king of
napa connects her right so he had this
idea right that's if people eat more
meat and drink more wine that will make
them healthier
right so to test this idea that they had
a decree right of that all the citizens
of baphilon they can only drink
wine and they can only eat meat they
can't eat vegetables and drink water
right so of course some citizens
complained
right um and then to
you know to appease the assistance he
does to run like a comparison test right
so over a period about 10 days there's
one group of citizens who would follow
the king's diet wine and meat there'll
be another group that followed their
normal diet of vegetables and water and
after 10 days this looking as people
went around to measure the health status
of these two groups of people and much
to his dismay the vegetable eating folks
actually looked healthier right so then
he had to go back some of the decrease
um
now of course over the last two
millennium rights
you know clinical trials have changed
quite a bit but many of the core tenants
stay the same right the idea is that we
want to study right in a relatively well
controlled setting the effects of a
particular intervention on the health
and outcomes of humans
right
so that's still the core idea and in
modern days right clinical trials is
really the bottleneck and that's the
gatekeeper of essentially oauth medicine
it's everything from cover vaccines to
cancer treatments right you have to go
through clinical trials
and the trials are also can be extremely
expensive
right like the
each trial can cost on the waters of
hundreds of millions of dollars and not
most of the trials fail right so they'll
account for the fact that many of these
trials fail the cost of actually taking
one drug through all these trials into
patients is on the waters of several
billions of dollars
so what i want to share with you today
are some of the ideas we've been
exploring about okay so now given that
these trials are so critical and they're
so expensive
um
in parallel we're also having a lot of
these real-world clinical genomics data
right by real-world data i mean if you
actually look at the medical records
right of cancer patients for example you
can look at other diseases of cancer
patients then we have for example
databases like the federal network which
has like two million cancer patients in
the u.s right for each of those patients
you know i know their first line
treatment their second line treatment
their biomarkers and their outcomes
and in parallel right for many of these
patients we also have their mutation
profiles because many of these patients
have actually taken foundation medicine
in gs based tests right before they
started first line treatment so right so
from tens of thousands of these patients
we also know their you know tumor
mutation profiles together we'll solve
their treatment information ehr records
right so those are the information that
we can in principle link and derive from
the medical records
so our idea here is that okay now that
we have all this data and say we can
link them right can we actually use this
data to sort of computationally run
clinical trials in silicon
right and the benefit of doing this i'll
show you two applications it's like
first we want to see if can we actually
use these computational oriental
clinical trials to actually help us to
design the actual randomized clinical
trials to make them more efficient and
also more inclusive more diverse
and second is can we actually use these
in circle trials basically identify
predictive biomarkers right so basically
genomic biomarkers that can tell us what
treatments are likely to benefit which
patients
okay
so uh so i'll tell you a bit about both
of these applications um first i just
want to give you a bit of a context
because people here may not be so
familiar with the clinical trials so
first i'll tell you about the first
piece right just how we can actually use
these kind of real world data clinical
genomics data to help us to design
clinical trials to make them more
efficient and more
you know more
representative
and this is based on this work that's
led by my phd student richaun lu who's a
fantastic phd student at stanford uh
that we published last year
where we developed this platform called
trial pathfinder which is like a
computational platform that helped us to
design these trials i'll tell you a bit
more about that in the next few slides
and we're very excited that actually
this trial pathfinder platform is now
actually used by pharma companies for
example by rosh genintex to inform the
designs of some of the new cancer trials
okay so what is the problem that we're
trying to solve right so if you actually
look at a design of a typical clinical
trial right one of the biggest pain
points right in designing this trial one
of the biggest complexities is she
decides actually what patients to enroll
in that clinical trial that's often one
of the biggest uh important decisions in
that given trial right so if you
actually look at the typical trial
protocol right so you'll have tens of
pages of pdf let's lay out specific
rules that says that if you had this
previous
condition or if your lab values focus on
some range where if we are taking this
treatment they are just not eligible to
participate in our upcoming trial
so these people are recognizing that
oftentimes clinical trials are just
overly restrictive right they're
excluding too many patients
and this has huge consequences both for
the patients because that makes it very
difficult for them to enroll in trials
for in cancer a large number of cancer
patients actually would like to
participate in cancer trials to get
access to cutting-edge treatment they're
not eligible
it also hurts the drug developers a lot
right so a substantial number of the
trials just simply fail to reach the
minimum enrollment requirement and for
every day it takes longer to enroll
patients actually a cost could be
costing a million dollars
the third consequence which is actually
very important you know from a data
science perspective right i guess it
means that
the fact that these clinical trials are
often overly restricted
means that you know they are typically
being evaluated on what are so-called
olympic athletes of the patients
right and how well treatment performs on
these olympic athletes do not really
necessarily reflect how well it works on
people like us
right so there's a distribution shift
right and that's people recognizing is
really one of the huge
weaknesses of the current design of
clinical trials
questions make sense
okay
so people might be wondering okay so how
how do people chronically design these
eligibility criteria and how do they end
up being so restricted
right um so when they design the lgbt
criteria for these trials right
oftentimes now you want to balance the
safety of the patients you want to make
sure that there's no adverse events and
also you want to you know sort of select
the patients to highlight the efficacy
of your treatment
right so those are sort of you know
multiple objectives that people are
trying to optimize for
um
and unfortunately right now there's
actually very little
uh or relatively little evidence-based
approaches for designing helpers to
design these trials right so most of
that is based on more anecdotes
so to illustrate this i actually took a
few screenshots of actual trial
protocols being designed right now all
right so someone drop a drop protocol
right um and the first thing that people
do is that they'll just copy and over
copy and paste over the
you know the trial that's done before by
the same team right
and then they'll go down like each line
of these so each line here corresponds
to one of the rules that's used to
exclude patients
right so the first line says that okay
if your neutrophil count is above some
outside of some range they are not
eligible to participate in this new
cancer trial
right and then you can see actually
there's uh on the sidebar of the google
doc it'll be actually discussion or some
would say okay can you can we relax this
threshold from fifteen hundred to a
thousand to enroll more patients right
somebody also push back and say oh we
don't really have evidence to change it
and the third person then would say oh
then
just keep it to be the same as before
right because we don't know what to do
otherwise
right and then for the next one for
hemoglobin with a similar discussion
right can you change it from nine to
eight to enroll more patients
no not enough evidence right so let's
keep it to be the same as before
so the upshot of this is that you know
how which
rules are used
to exclude patients
very much depends on sort of the history
of the clinical team itself or the
history of the companies right it's a
very anecdotal
process uh and here i'm showing you
there are ten different
advanced nonsense cell non-small cell
lung transfer trials
right um
so each row is one of the trials each
column corresponds to one of the
commonly used rules
that are often used by companies to
exclude patients because some of these
are based on you know biomarkers lab
tests prior treatments right
or previous diagnosis
and i colored it to be yellow if that
particular trial used that rule to
exclude patients otherwise colored gray
you can see that actually even across
the same indication often looking at the
same kind of similar drugs similar
mechanisms these are
different immunotherapies but the
different companies end up having wildly
different rules for building their
cohorts just because the process is so
anecdotal for everyone
um and everybody's recognizing this is a
huge challenge right so for example the
national cancer institute said that the
designs of all the clinical trials needs
to be made simpler and more standardized
um
but how to do this in a data-driven way
is challenging and this is where we want
to help with the trial python algorithm
okay
so that's the
setup for the problem right so now
stepping back you know as a computer
scientist uh data scientist right so
um then the problem at the core
as a is it really a data science problem
but counterfactuals
right so we have a set of patients right
who are excluded from participating in
these clinical trials what i want to
know is sort of the contra factor of
were these patients were excluded would
they have or which of them would have
actually safely benefited from the
treatment that's tested in the clinical
trial
and the idea that we have for doing this
is that
the it's the leverage fact that many of
the patients even if they're not
eligible to participate in the clinical
trial now after the drug is approved
after it comes to the market many of the
same patients end up taking the same
drugs after it comes to the market
right so many of the drugs actually even
use off-label after they come on the
market
right so then if we could just identify
these patients in the medical recruits
right um then we can try to answer these
kind of counterfactuals in a systematic
way
and to do this we leverage the data from
the flat iron network that i mentioned
before we have ehr data from you know a
large number of cancer patients they
cover about 2 million cancer patients in
the u.s across many not 200 plus
different clinics in the us
and for many of those patients right so
for all of them we have sort of the
treatments and vitals and biomarkers and
for many of them we also have the
genomic profiles
okay so here's sort of the schematic
right of how we do this i want to give
you an intuition and the details are in
in this paper
so the idea here is you know here's how
we actually use the ehr to actually
computationally emulate the cloud in
silico right so say they have a
particular trial the trial will have
some treatment drugs right there may be
an immunotherapy we'll have some control
could be chemotherapy and you'll have a
set of rules for excluding patients in
this case maybe you only want to have
patients with bilirubin less than once a
bilirubin it's a commonly used
assessment of liver function
so then what we do is that we go into
our medical records right so we can
generate synthetic cohorts we'll
generate one cohort of patients who
actually took the treatment right across
all these different clinics
um and who satisfies this threshold
building less than one will generate
another synthetic cohorts of patients
who took the controls but also satisfy
the threshold
now these two cohorts of patients will
look very different maybe they have
different demographics and different
distributions
so then we can sort of computationally
match these distributions to make them
comfortable right
um just as an aside right so to do this
matching there's a lot of interesting
this is where there's a lot of
interesting machine learning statistical
techniques right so you can
do things like you can do use propensity
based methods since the data is very
high dimensional you want to use them
for machine learning predictors on top
of the presidency based methods
we've also developed approaches based on
for optimal transport basically also
another approach for aligning these data
distributions
but the main point here and i can
describe this more in detail but the
main point here is that you want to
basically match these distributions so
they're they're comfortable to emulate
sort of this randomization process in
actual clinical trial but after you do
this then you can sort of measure things
like what is the hazard ratio and what
is the outcome of these two synthetic
cohorts
and because it's all down in silicon
it's actually very easy for us to change
competitively change these different
thresholds right so i could say
maybe philadelphia less than one is too
restrictive what if i make change that
to be more inclusive to be less than two
to enroll more patients right so then i
have larger synthetic cohorts because i
can find more people in the medical
records right who satisfies the
broader rules but then i can do the
distribution matching again and look at
the outcomes
and the idea here is that by
computationally changing these
thresholds if i don't actually see any
difference in the outcomes but if i
don't see more adverse events if i don't
see worsening of the survival of
patients then that gives us evidence
that perhaps we can actually broadening
this
restriction of the building values from
one to two or within this threshold
so that's the high level intuition
so at this point you might have like you
know maybe a few questions
right um first question you might ask is
okay so what if the drug is actually not
on the market right because everything
i've said so far relies on the fact that
we have to look in the medical records
to find patients who are taking these
drugs right what if it's not on the
markets
uh it's a good question so oftentimes
what we do here is we leverage fact that
you actually often have drugs
of similar mechanisms of action or even
the same drug that have previously been
tested before that are on the market
it's actually because most of the
clinical trials especially in cancer
obviously are testing
uh a run on drugs that are already
approved for some other indications
so we have the information from those
that aren't found in ehr
another thing you might wonder about is
that okay so what about confounders in
this observational data right so here
we're looking at non-randomized
observational data so that is a true
limitation of any
kind of this kind of analysis
we do benefit here from because we have
very highly curated ehr data right so we
follow patients over many years we have
their genomic profiles and their
treatment and outcomes
and but in the end we also validate our
results with data from actual randomized
clinical trials
yeah
it's through a direction but um
the way that you're you're sending the
drugs it's very highly buoyant right
because i mean yes trucks may not be in
the market
yeah and so the population of drugs that
survive may have very different risk
behavior in the overall population
because they have been vetted to real
clinical trials isn't that a problem in
the long run i mean similar drugs and
same mode of action set aside but
something that is really novel um
yeah so it's a good question so what
we're trying to do is we want to be
represented
of drugs that are in certain phase two
phase three stages of clinical trials we
actually go to the clinical drug product
government basically all the phase two
phase three drugs all right so
it's true that even the phase two drugs
are certainly a society set up all the
drugs right but that's from the ones
that ends up making it the most part of
the biggest impact
yeah
so
you were only measuring the hazard ratio
there how do you take care of the
adverse events yes we have multiple
outcomes right so we have mortality
this is one outcome we can look at time
for progression right time to death we
can also have measures like you know
time to average events right what's
adverseness here could be some toxicity
events how do you weigh all of these
things across each other so right now we
don't weigh them which is actually look
at each of them separately right so
because you can just see of course how
does changing this uh
eligibility rules affect high resistance
effects
survival affects each of the outcomes
there's still a subjective assessment
after that whether you want to so we'll
actually end up seeing that there is a
sweet spot where you can actually relax
these rules and actually get sort of a
crater optimal for all of these apps for
all these metrics
okay good questions so so just to
summarize right so here's the project so
we start off with you know this
trial protocol which is written in
natural language we can do some nlp to
basically extract computational rules
right of defining the cohorts from these
trial protocols those are encoded
as logic statements then we actually go
into the actual medical records like of
these millions of patients to generate
our synthetic cohorts like i described
before
we can customer computational match them
right using statistical approaches and
then look at the outcomes right by all
of these metrics right the adverse
events survival progression et cetera
and we don't just do this once right
because this is only in silicon we
actually do this millions of times in
parallel each time we do this we
actually use a different combination of
eligibility rules and the reason why we
do this is try to really assess the
impact of different specific eligibility
rules because there could be
interactions between them
and at the end right after these
millions of
trials then we sort of summarize all
these results together
using this sort of technique that we
developed across our uh
criteria sharply values to to summarize
the impact of this each of these
eligibility rules
so just to give you a sort of concrete
sense of what this looks like right
again going back to our example of the
bilirubin right uh you know so here are
these ten different advanced nonstomach
lung cancer trials and they end up you
know using different bilirubin
thresholds for excluding patients
right so for each of these trial which
is one of these curve here we can
actually then have
in silico trials right that says like
what this trial would have looked like
if i just change the bilirubin threshold
by holding everything else fixed
all right so each of this curve
curvature corresponds to the contour
factors of changing the ability to
threshold and the y-axis is basically
like a hazard ratio it's a lower is
better
but the main point here is that actually
within a reasonable range right you
could actually change the exclusion
criteria of this rule by making it
more inclusive right enroll more
patients without actually hurting
yourself in terms of the hazard ratios
right so without
engendering safety of the patients
and then by doing this systematically we
come up with a set of data driven
recommendations server guidelines for
these lung cancer trials
so we applied this to a bunch of
different cancer types like breast
cancer
melanoma but here i'm showing you the
results from the advanced non-supercell
lung cancer so we applied it to those
are 10 different trials from different
pharma companies
um
and it's maybe the most important things
from the last row here which is sort of
the you know what these trials look like
under the original designs from the
pharma companies right that's proposed
and what it looks like and there are
data-driven criteria
so on average we show that by taking
this data-driven approach approach for
design and eligibility of these trials
we can more than double the number of
eligible patients
while actually still reducing the hazard
ratio overall
right so this means that actually many
of the patients who were systematically
excluded from these trials before
they would have actually benefited to a
similar or even greater extent
compared to the more olympic athletes of
patients that were eligible
and importantly the data driven approach
what we have here actually enables a lot
more women and more minorities and older
patients to access those trials many of
them were systematically excluded before
so just to summarize this part right um
i think this is our one first step to
taking a data-driven approach to design
clinical trials to make them more
efficient and safer and more inclusive
um
we
i didn't have time to talk about here
but we actually validated our designs
using data from actually randomized
clinical trials right because there's
actually turned out to be a lot of
natural variation which gives us
opportunity to do to opportunity to do
sort of natural experiments
also using data from different cohorts
outside of flat iron
um here we mostly talk about cancer but
i think similar kind of methodologies
can also be extended to other disease
types
um and now we're very excited that
that we published paper last year and
this actually now is being used by
pharma companies uh it was also
recognized by the pharma industry as one
of the top data science innovations in
the past year
okay so more briefly so the second part
i want to mention is you know how we can
actually use these similar kinds of
approaches the silicone trials to do uh
precision oncology so this is based on
paper that that we wrote which is just
just came out last week
so the idea here is that i mentioned
that you know for large number of these
patients but in addition to their
medical records we also have their
genomic profiles from because they've
taken the foundation medicine testing
right and we have these profiles before
the first line they started treatment
uh and the data we have is usually about
though you have ngs sequencing for many
of the several hundred of the key cancer
driver genes
and what very interesting is to look for
yes just to make sure this foundation
the data data
something only like
five mutations per individual so is it
enough data to go
yeah so they basically they search for a
panel made for about six or 500 plus
genes
and then they do
quite detail like
they do ngr sequencing for all each of
those genes and we actually do find uh
so this is actually structure we
actually do find quite a large number of
mutations
for many of the patients
and we look at this across eight of the
common cancer types
and what we are really interested in
doing from this is to basically look for
mutation treatment interactions right by
taking this synthetic digital cohort
approach so what does that mean like
what do i mean by mutation treatment
interactions
right so for example this is one kind of
interaction with identified right so if
you look at all the bladder cancer
patients right we'll go to our medical
records and find other bladder cancer
patients we can generate a cohort of all
these plantar cancer patients who are
taking immunotherapy
right so there's large number of them
and then we can find okay so among those
bladder cancer patients who are taking
immunotherapy some of them will have a
mutation in this gene called apc right
which is a tumor suppressor gene
and these patients actually end up
having much better survival outcome
compared to other bladder cancer
patients who are also taking
immunotherapy but did not have mutations
in this gene apc
right
and conversely we can also ask a
complementary question right among all
the patients with apc mutation now is
immunotherapy actually the best
treatment for them
in this case it seems like the ones that
are taking immunotherapy also have
better survival outcomes compared to the
ones who are given other treatments
could be chemo or targeted therapies
right and mathematically this
corresponds to basically looking for
these kind of interaction effects right
between the mutation which is the
genotype here and the specific treatment
which in this case is immunotherapy
um and because we have these large
cohorts we can basically do this
systematically for every single mutation
and for every treatment that's on the
market
basically look for all the possible
interactions yes
so the data that's part of the
foundation it's not a randomized trial
right it's basically
patients who asked for the foundation
panel to be done on their
uh
isn't there already a bias in there the
type of patients who go for that one are
you missing something here
um yes so so a selected set of patients
um but it's you know the test is pretty
commonly done so there's like 200 000
patients who have taken the foundation
medicine test
um
i don't think that bias necessarily
affect this kind of results or because
this says that's you know conditional
taking a foundation medicine test right
there's still a very strong interaction
in fact it's more than you have apc
mutation versus white when you don't
have apc mutation
but that's a good question because four
but um
the next thing we did is actually we
validated these findings using data from
actual randomized clinical trials
all right so the previous results all
come from looking at this the medical
records and we look for these
interactions but in this particular case
right we actually uh you know so
rosh actually
run a randomized clinical trial of
bladder cancer patients uh when they're
given a peso which means immunotherapy
they also don't foundation medicine
tests for all these patients in a
randomized file
and we can identify sort of similar kind
of effect right that there is this
positive interaction between apc
immunotherapy so patients who have apc
had much better survival outcomes when
giving immunotherapy exactly as we have
predicted from our initial analysis
a real situation and not in a clinical
trial there is often a situation that
according to the response of the patient
the the drug is changed the regime
change so you don't
have the you know the whole survival
kill because events happen
yeah
that's a good question so there we look
at multiple outcomes so overall survival
is one common outcome we can also look
at time for progression what that means
is that how long did the patients how
long did this particular immunotherapy
work before it stopped working so the
patient had to move on to the next line
of treatments so that time itself is
actually a useful indication of how
effective that human is so we have we
also simply show that the similar kinds
of you know apc immunotherapy
interaction even when we look at time
for progression to the next slide
okay so that's just one example um now
but the power of doing this
in silico approach across all the
possible mutation treatments
combinations that we can actually now
discover from the real clinical data
right
a much larger number of these kind of
predictive biomarkers here i'm just
showing a subset of them but um you know
in our
paper we actually have a full list
of over 400 of these markers so each
marker will be you know similar to the
apc story right so for example
here like you know you look at a
particular
kind of treatment like maybe
immunotherapy and advanced non-small
cell lung cancer right and then for
particular treatment class we can see
that okay if you have like k-rats
mutations then you're more likely to
benefit from you know immunotherapy if
you have egr mutations you're less
likely to benefit right so the color
here is blue that means that there's a
positive interaction between that
mutation and treatment that means that
there's a negative interaction
and we're very excited about this as a
potential first to generate a lot of
interesting research hypothesis but also
as a way really for treatment
recommendations for uh you know
precision medicine
because each of these predictive
biomarkers leads to a very specific and
actionable treatment recommendation of
which patients which treatment is likely
to benefit that particular patient
first question you are showing it on the
gene
level are you
clustering together all the mutations in
the gene or is it typically one notation
yeah so we look at um different
resolutions so here is four simplified
visualizations shown in gene level but
we also look at very specific subtypes
of mutations
like for example like translocation
truncations will have that subtypes
um and
also we also look for a sort of gnt
interactions
right basically we have enough data to
show that maybe it goes back to earlier
questions we have an updated show that
the same patient actually has multiple
mutations right maybe they have both
like
translocation but in addition to that
they also have a mutation in tp53 or
sdk11 right so then we can look for that
interaction effect of how much that
patient right would benefit from
targeted therapy if they have an
additional mutation in tp53 or sdk11
right so here are basically the kind of
interaction maps that we can identify
here for example that systems you know
if you have a patient who are given
k-ras targeted therapy
right and if they have additional
mutations in epc then that actually
means that the chaos therapy itself is
going to be much more effective
so that that's the blue here is a
positive interaction
um so yeah so we um together with the
paper we also released uh who created
this precision
dot work which is to visualize and
summarize all of these results we have
here uh so there's a lot of data
information here of the specific
mutation subtypes and interactions to
all these treatments and so hopefully
this would be like a useful resource for
the broader research community
so just to summarize i think the core
technical idea here is that now that we
have these linked large clinical
genomics data rights i think one really
promising way to leverage that data is
to basically use it to run in circle
trials
and we've shown here that you can
actually use these instant controls to
help us in designs of the actual
clinical trials to make them more
efficient more safer and more inclusive
right so that's you know really one of
the key mandates of of the nci of fda
and we can also use them to discover
these predictive biomarkers which can be
greatly helpful for physician medicine
precision oncology
and there are certain limitations of
working with this real-world clinical
oncology data
which many of people here have mentioned
these are real limitations which is why
we do still think that it's very
important to validate all of our results
with the actual randomized clinical
trials
so i'll stop here and just want to
acknowledge again um a student region
our collaborators
at roche and genotech as well as other
collaborators at stanford
for um for all of these projects
so you're basically using this to
optimize cohorts for future studies
you also mentioned that correctly that
you know the previous trials were often
unrealistic cohorts which are not really
with the representative real
population so i think you could also use
this framework to
reassess the existing drugs in the
market but essentially silicon
reconstructing
the criteria of the original study
and then comparing the performance of
the drug on the subset of patients to
the whole population of patients in
order to see how much
worse different better the drug actually
performs on this you know extended core
yeah that's a great question um we have
looked into that
and it turns out that there is a
systematic
overestimation of the results in the
clinical trial compared to the results
in the real world we see here but that
also has been reported previously in
many other studies
so to people there's there's no
recognition that the clinical trial
results even if it's randomized and
perfectly controlled right since being
biased
upward in terms of their effect size
so after a drug has been approved
are there additional data for a teacher
like people who take the treatment they
do better
worse i mean that would be more relevant
exactly so that's exactly the data that
we use from the ehr because we know that
the drugs have been improved right this
person on medical records right they
take that drug and we know their
outcomes exactly right so that's exactly
what we use yeah
so that's why we go to these hundreds of
clinics where they're created by flat
iron to look at millions of cancer
patients who actually end up taking
these drugs after they've been improved
thank you